hey guys today HBO has released four
short clips entitled it's what connects
us parts of the same from a series as a
recently published from one that was
published in front of the big little
lies finale which is popular direct
comedy drama miniseries on HBO on Sunday
night in front of the finale of already
mention miniseries HBO decided to air
new promo which of course besides all
other main characters of the other
popular series and all other popular
people from the network also included
few main characters of their most
popular series Game of Thrones that's
interesting and funny promo included
Jaime Lannister Daenerys Targaryen tone
Sansa brain and Jon Snow and all of them
alongside all other popular people from
the network are literally saying in to
today's release clips that are in the
same promo series we can see some
characters some in their new outfits
some of the same outfits they've been
wearing in previous season but all of
them are saying ah well almost all of
them as holder can only say holder and
as Daenerys cats or dragons to roll for
her the reason why all of them are
saying are in recently published from
and today released one is because they
are trying to imitate you know a place
before every HBO show while the more
important tag for us Game of Thrones
fans is that some game of turtles
characters are wearing their new season
7 outfits if you're wondering how do we
know if outlets which they are wearing
in this promo series will be used in the
upcoming season the answer is pretty
simple so let's just put it this way
it's already been confirmed from either
the leaked photos that have been leaked
months ago or from Game of Thrones
Season 7 official promo that has been
published a week ago however in those
two new release clips the first game of
Thrones character that appears in Cersei
Lannister saying ah in the stunning
outfit which she also wears is season 7
promo trailer while in primer released a
few days ago Johnston was rushing
everyone in today released one he's
saying ah just as in season 7 promo
trailer and in the previous version of
this funny promo John is very heavy
cloak with animal fur which Sansa Stark
may then gave him in the fifth episode
of
sixth season next character that is
saying the same word as all the others
this Tyrion Lannister is pretty much
most of them Tyrion is also very new
dark outfit similar to missing days
which we could already seem like photos
tormund also made his appearance in this
funny promo he's wearing heavy animal
fur common for the wildlings from the
haunted forest long story short the same
outfit from the previous season but
there's something new though cut on his
forehead which might be an official
confirmation that we're going to see
night Kings ambush on Jon Snow and his
team that'll include torment all trying
to capture white a theory that quickly
became a confirmed event of season 7 due
to more than a few and assailable proofs
an event which you can check out for
more details in my previous videos a few
months later
Daenerys appeared in her black outfit
with a red cloak linked with a silver
chain that has dragon motives the same
outfit from the season 7 promo trailer
and also the same outfit that she has
been wearing while shooting scenes for
the upcoming season in Spain as the
nurse is known as mother of dragons then
he only raised her finger central dragon
did the rest but however in the second
version of this same promo
she'll imitates HBO central is the
others just a storm and Jaime Lannister
team Greyjoy Davos and very sir also
wearing the same outfit they've been
varying in previous season but I have to
admit Jaime staring to his golden hen
and saying ah is the funniest moment of
the short video value hound and Brienne
are looking stunning in their new
outfits there can also be seen in third
branch Stark who is working at the time
but it's also seemingly having a new
outfit
just as in previously released version
which is once again confirming that bran
Stark will finally reunited his siblings
at Winterfell
at some point of the upcoming season
there are also stark sisters sent signed
her dark-themed outfit and Arya in her
new Norton outfit with needle in her
hands for the end let's just highlight
that this promo series also contains
holder who is finally saying the only
word he was capable of saying koto which
accompanied with the fact that this
promo series is clearly focused on the
upcoming season as many of them are very
new ounces it's metal that holder might
make reappearance in the upcoming season
gives me a saw that a previous video my
ninja brooch
in which holder could have been raised
from to that but white walkers in order
to act as their minion could come back
as a white that theory might be
confirmed by this promo and as always
let me know your opinion about all of
this in the comment section down below I
hope you guys enjoyed this video if you
did please make sure to subscribe to our
Channel and I hope to see you in the
next one peace
[Music]
you
[Music]